[Musique]
vingt à trente mille personnes étaient
venues cette année encore pendant deux
jours pour visiter la foire de saint
tollé en dordogne avec ses expositions
de matériels agricoles
c'est indispensable marchand de frites
et ses inévitables camelot le champ de
foire de la latière présentait le visage
habituel à ce genre de manifestation et
pourtant
l'insolite était au rendez vous cette
année en effet mardi à 14 heures
on invitait à grand renfort de musique
et de haut parleurs
on invitait donc les visiteurs a assisté
à un enterrement cérémonie funèbre bien
particulière que celle ci montre
l'emplacement choisi entre le pc de la
croix-rouge et le stand d'une agence de
voyages il fallait en plus acquitter un
droit d'entrée de 5 francs dernière
particularité et non des moindres
monsieur ange et laiise assistait à sa
propre inhumation ils allaient d'être
enterré vif le premier faux pas touchés
c'est l'autre celui là n'était ne donner
que par celui là alors je me rappelle
toi oui la bac est derrière alors une
fois l'ordre elle alors qu'elle avait 12
jours
bon alors là aussi il faut tourner je
lui a retourné comme ça on vous dira un
peu à droite ou à gauche
comment ça devait est à deux heures et
demie mais à ce moment là on dès 13h55
parce que le temps de se préparer aux
abords pour quand même et à l'heure et
c'est vous qui avez inventé sûr que
qu'est-ce qu'ils votent particulier elad
particulier tout
maintenant tout est branché la tête les
bras tout la sécurité à l'intérieur
aurait stephen marié vous avez lire
supplémentaire qui est ici vous avez
transformé beauté et il ya le petit
système qu'ils disent qu'il faut
toujours avoir confiance au fil à tous
mais des fois la soudure des coffrets
louper face entre autres à deux kivu
pour réparer comme les fausses preuves
et lors de l'autre côté c'est exactement
pareil
en bref tout est à l'heure actuelle
suffit pour moi c'est la dame ça score
tout au point et à l'oissu lacroix
carnassiers saas comme tout pareil pour
été révélé et alors on reste tous les
mains assassines derrière de la tête sur
la besoins de l'élève
quand je préfère de préparation avec vos
petits systèmes pc est assez compliquée
avec au moins
pas tellement
apple a manqué
et alors j'ai trompé cech qui sont
derrière je peux quand même si c'est
assez et je peux aller tout réparer d'un
côté comme de l'autre même au bout des
pieds mais c'est quand même assez
dangereux non mais c'est dangereux où je
serai très bien que je suis là qui
plombe et le suppression d'un lot c'est
qu'il a aidé s'en sortir alors suis-je
prochain bol des idées pour le champagne
après qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée
monsieur haïssent d'inventer un tel
cercueil
mais c'est à cause que gmac est enterré
vivant intellectuellement ans je l'aï ce
n'est sûrement pas comme tout le mais
s'il est différent il ne l'est pas
jusqu'au point de sauter un repas
la preuve une heure avant sa
démonstration il était attablé avec ses
amis voilà mon rêve pour deux jours ça
peut l'être à cacher un peu de garder la
pêche est pour ça qu il veut venir vous
voulez envoyer un courrier séparé de
boue et de moi je le mettrai ça se crée
plus tard en europe
un petit citron parce que j'ai toujours
mal à la gorge on sait bien mais en sus
un citron se met à la planche en plus de
ça les petits trucs 1 reste le reste
derrière violent si des fois on y
respecte sait pas on en l'air des terres
friande un peu payant les gants crise on
l'a alors si par hasard il est un jour
de plus j'aime réserves supplémentaires
une petite bouteille de vin 1907 à rio
c'est pas grave c'est du vin biologique
parce que moi je me soigne
[Musique]
alors si vous voulez dépêchez vous
messieurs dames si vous voulez entre
évident très vite dans quelques instants
et en perd là et jeunes hommes allaient
penser donc elle acquiesce d'avancé
devant assez pas sur le côté
mardi à 15 heures quand je l'aï ce
voyait le couvercle de son cercueil se
refermer au dessus de lui
mais rassurez-vous il allait revoir le
jour 30 heures plus tard tout avait
l'ombre bien fonctionné l'argent était
rentré dans les caisses et les voyants
lumineux avaient prouver le sérieux de
l'invention
ainsi donc rangel pouvait savourer son
bonheur et l'organisateur calculer ses
bénéfices angèle haïssent un inventeur
peut être génial mais sans doute aussi
un petit peu naïve
[Musique]